une insigne comme récompense vendredi 2
juillet marque la fin de stage des
cadets de la gendarmerie
trente jeunes des yvelines et du val
d'oise ont participé pendant un an à ce
dispositif
l'objectif faire découvrir les métiers
de la gendarmerie et tous en garde un
souvenir particulier je vois maintenant
quand on est tous soudés on marche main
dans la main et on partage tous le même
objectif c'est d'intégrer la gendarmerie
et ce qui fait justement on a une très
forte amitié qui s'est basé là dessus je
vais en garder un très très bon et un
très très bon souvenir car je pense que
c'est quelque chose qu'on vit pas tous
dans une vie et je vais garder un très
bon souvenir
mis en place en 2010 est ce dispositif
est un partenariat entre la gendarmerie
l'éducation nationale et l'état
tous les volontaires sont âgés de 17 à
21 ans ils sont recrutés sur des
critères sociaux géographique de
motivation et de revenus beaucoup
d'entre eux sont issus de quartiers
politique de la ville je pense qu'il ya
un enjeu également d'information de
promotion de sensibilisation ces
dispositifs dans certains coins de la
république on n'est pas totalement
informés de du panel de dispositifs qui
peut exister pour justement faire de
cette citoyenneté une citoyenneté active
grâce à un enseignement scolaire et
trois stages les cadets se prépare pour
le concours d'entrée de la gendarmerie
de quoi mettre un premier pas dans le
métier beaucoup de jeunes des fois ne
veulent pas s'inscrire aux concours
parce qu'ils ont peur
tout simplement il ya une peur une
hantise liés aux concours or ces jeunes
ils ont des fois les savoir-faire les
savoirs est qui permettrait d'être de
bons gendarmes donc cet accompagnement
scolaire
cette préparation concours vont leur
permettre justement de préparer le
concours et de l'obtenir les banques qui
puisse inspirer intégrer les rangs de la
gendarmerie en septembre le dispositif
va s'étendre 120 places seront ouvertes
dès la rentrée prochaine
90 places de plus que les années
précédentes